[موسيقى]
مساء الخير انتهت واقعه المنطاد الصيني
فوق الاجواء الامريكيه لكننا نتائجه لم
تنتهي بعد لو ان هناك دوله واحده مستفيده
من هذه الواقعه العجيبه الغريبه فهي روسيا
يقينا رئيسها بوتين صلى شكر لله بعد ان
قرر الامريكان ضرب هذا المنطاد بصاروخ هذه
الحادثه عمقت من التوتر والخلاف الصيني
الامريكي وانقذت روسيا من تقارب صيني
امريكي ولو مؤقت على حسابه
لم يشتري الامريكان هذه الروايه واكدوا
مره اخرى على انه
عسكري هدفه التجسس على المنشات الامريكيه
الحساسه وقرروا ضربه حين يكون الوقت
والمكان مناسب اي بعيدا عن اماكن تجمع
السكان
واصدر الرئيس الامريكي امرا يوم 4 فبراير
الماضي بضربه وضرب بالصاروخ من مقاتله اف
وسقط في مياه المحيط الاطلنطي قباله سواحل
كارولينا الجنوبيه وفي الوقت الحالي بتقوم
جهات متعدده بجمع انقاده لفحصها ومعرفه
التكنولوجيا الصينيه المستخدمه فيه
ومحاوله الوقوف على اي معلومات ربما يكون
قد جمعها وارسلها الى الصينيين
هذا هو ما حدث رد فعل الصين
عبر عن غضب الصينيين وقالوا
متمسكين برواياتهم ان الامريكان استخدموا
قوه غير ضروريه ضد هدف مدني وامعانا في
التاكيد على روايتهم قاموا باقاله رئيس
هيئه الارصاد الجويه الصينيه باعتباره
مسؤولا عن هذه الواقعه لكن لهم احتفظوا
لانفسهم بحق الرد على الامريكان اي حقهم
في تدمير اي اسس او اصول امريكيه بالونز
او اي يعني طائرات او اي وسائل للتجسس
تخترق اجوائهم وما اكثرها في السنوات
الكثيره الماضيه
الواقعه دي واقعه صغيره في تقديري لعده
اسباب اوله المفروض ان تكون صغيره يعني
لعده اسباب اولها ان كل دول العالم تتجسس
على كل دول العالم وبالتالي حين تكتشف
دوله انها مخترقه من دوله اخرى بتتصرف
بشكل كونتيند ومحتوى ومنضبط لان هذه وقائع
متكرره كثيرا ليس فقط بين الدول اللي
علاقتها متوتره ببعضها البعض ولكن حتى بين
الحلفاء سوف اعطيكم
مثال او اثنين
بسبب يعني عنصر الوقت والامثله لا تقع تحت
حصر على كل حال الولايات المتحده مثلا
اللي هي بتتجسس على كل دول العالم حلفائها
قبل اعدائها ضبطت في فضيحه تجسس كبرى على
حليفته المانيا
وانكشف هذه انكشفت هذه الفضيحه في منتصف
2015 حين تبين ان الامريكان يتجسسون منذ
سنوات على
على هواتف 125 مسؤول الماني على راسهم
المستشاره انجيلا امريكا ومرت المساله
بسلام على الاقل لم يكن هناك اي توابع
امام الراي العام في العالم اسرائيل ضبطت
اكثر من مره متلبسه بالتجسس على الامريكان
مره في 21 حين ضبطوا بالتجسس على هواتف
مسؤولين في الخارجيه الامريكيه وطبعا
واقعه
الجاسوس جونثون بولرد
الشهيره اللي حكم عليه ب 30 سنه سجنا
لتورته في التجسس على امريكا لصالح
اسرائيل معروفه للجميع وبالتالي الجميع
يتجسس على الجميع
ليس في هذا جديد ولا يقتدي في كل مره ان
يتحول الى فضيحه ويوتر العلاقه بين
العلاقات بين بلدين خصوصا بانه امريكا
اعلنت عن طريق صحفها يعني لم تعلن رسميا
ولكن تسربت لكل صحفها الكبرى في يوليو
2022 انها تطور
مناطيد وبالونات للتجسس عنها كل من الصين
وروسيا
بالمناسبه استخدام المناطيل للتجسس مساله
قديمه طبعا والكل دلوقتي بات يعلم انه
المناطيل بتستخدم من نهايه القرن ال 18
وان الفرنسيين كانوا اول من استخدموها
للاغراض العسكريه انه يعني
اخترعوا منطاد ويعتليه الجنود ويراقبهم
هيادين المعارك واستخدم في الحرب العالميه
الاولى والثانيه وكان بيستخدم للتجسس على
نطاق واسع في الحرب البارده واغراض عسكريه
اخرى
يعني مثلا الواقعه الشهيره وفقا للروايه
الامريكيه انه في منتصف 1947 انه كان
الامريكان بيراقبه سرا تجارب نوويه ما
كانش عاوزين حد يعرف عنها فاستخدمه من طاج
المنطاد ده سقط بالقرب من مدينه روزويل في
نيوميكس ولان الامريكان ما كانش عندهم اي
فكره عن التجارب النوويه السريه ولا
المنطاد اللي بيراقبها فاعتقدوا ان هذا
يعني واحد من الاطباق الطائره ودي قصه محل
خلاف لكن على الاقل بتشير الى استخدام
المنطاد من وقت المبكر
المنطاد لسه لي رغم تعدد وسائل التجسس
مزايا بتدفع الدول
واجهزه الاستخبارات للتمسك باستخدامه رغم
وجود يعني ستلايتس ووجودرونز وطائرات
متخصصه في التجسس وبيقولوا انه هذا
المنطاد او المناطيب بصفه عامه هي رخيصه
لا تلفت الانتباه على عكس الحاله
الاستثنائيه في المثال الصيني اللي دعا
الناس انه يعطي تفسيرات اخرى بما انه كان
ملفت للنظر بهذا الشكل لكن عاده المنطاد
لا يصدر عوادم لا يلفت النظر رخيص عنده
قدره على انه يحوم حوالين الهدف المراقب
لفتره طويله وبالتالي جمع كل المعلومات
المطلوبه خاصه انه يحلق على مستوى منخفض
نسبيا نتكلم 18 20 كيلو فوق سطح الارض
مقارنه اللي بتتراوح ابعاده من 160
اذا كان هدفه التصوير والمراقبه والتجسس
على كل حال مزايا المنطاد العسكريه
واغراض التجسس ليس موضوعنا انا بس بقولها
لانه بيجيب على اسئله اخرى ماذا كانت تفعل
الصين بهذا المنطاد الامريكان تحدثوا
كثيرا عن القواعد العسكريه المهمه اللي
كان هذا المنطاد بيحوم حولها في منطقه
مونتانا قواعد اطلاق قواعد الصواريخ بعيده
المدى وقواعد الرادارات العسكريه المتقدمه
على كل الاحوال هذه في التفاصيل لكن في كل
الاحوال هذه واقعه متكرره كان يمكن ان
تكون في حجم اصغر
خصوصا ان البنت تكون خرج وقال انه يستبعد
ان يكون هذا المنطاد قد جمع او حصل اي
معلومات النوفل نوفل انت ليجنس ما يعني
انه كل المعلومات التي يمكن ان يكون قد
حصل عليها لابد انها مت للصينيين اللي
عندهم زي كل الدول الكبيره وسائل متعدده
لقراءه كل المشهد على الاراضي الامريكيه
كما ان الامريكان قادرين على قراءه المشهد
كله ومعرفه تفاصيل الكثير من التفاصيل
العسكريه الصينيه
طب لماذا
اخذت حادثه المنطاد كل هذا البعد واحد او
يعني ضخمت جدا واحد طبعا الهوس الامريكي
الامريكي بالصين في السنوات الاخيره
الصين اصبحت هوس امريكي فاي شيء بياتي من
الصين اذا كان تيك توك او قنصليه صينيه او
طبعا منطاد يمثل يعني
خطرا كبيرا
وخطا ومسار قلق للامريكان وبالتالي كل ما
ياتي من الصين فهو مثير للقلق زي ما كان
كل ما ياتي من الاتحاد السوفيتي في اثناء
الحرب البارده يمثل خطر المبالغ فيه جدا
بالنسبه للامريكان هذا اولا لكن ثانيا هو
طبعا الاجواء الانقسام العامه في الولايات
المتحده في السنوات الاخيره ما بين
الجمهورين والديمقراطيين واللي بتزيد جدا
بدايه من هذه الايام اللي هي اجواء
المبكره الحملات الانتخابيه في 2024 ولذلك
راينا انقساما ضخما جدا بين الديمقراطين
والجمهوريين الجمهوريين بيتهموا اداره
الرئيس الامريكي بانها اداره ضعيفه مرتشه
وانه لو لم يكن ضعيفا ومرتعشا ما تجرا
الصينيون على اختراق الاجواء الامريكيه
بمنطاد بحجم الثلاث حافلات ثلاث اتوبيسات
بيحلق فوق الاجواء الامريكيه وهما يعلموا
ان الاداره الامريكيه اداره ضعيفه ويرد
عليها الديمقراطيين
البالون الصيني اخترق الاكواء الامريكيه 3
مرات في عهد الرئيس ترامب ولم تفعله شيئا
ووصل الخلاف الى حد انه بعض النواب
الديمقراطيين الامريكان طالبوا الرئيس
الامريكي بالاستقاله بسبب سوء ادائه في
هذه الواقعه
وبالتالي اجواء الانتخابات
يعني جعلت من هذه قضيه راي عام واستغلها
الجمهوريون للانقضاض على الرئيس الامريكي
واصبحت قضيه راي عام اضف الى كده انه اصلا
في خلاف ما بين الامريكان غالبيه كاسحه
ترى انه يجب مواصله الضغط على الصينيين
باعتبارهم يعني خصم لدودا بل عدو وفئه
صغيره بتطالب بتهدئه الاجواء
الخفه القليله اللي بتطالب بتهدئه الاجواء
دي بترى انه ليس من مصلحه الامريكان تصعيد
الخلاف مع الصين على كل الصعد فلنتنافس
فيما يجب ان نتنافس فيه ولنتعاون فيما
نستطيع التعاون فيه او عليه
وبالتالي في
يعني
الهوس الصيني سبب واضح جدا لتوتير هذه
الحادثه التي كانت يمكن ان تمر لو كان
البالون له اي جنسيه اخرى طبعا في اسباب
اخرى كثيره في ناس مستفيده اصحاب مصالح من
وجود توتر في العلاقه ما بين امريكا
والصين اسباب بزنس بحث يعني مثلا مثلا كل
شركات الاحتكاريه الامريكيه اللي مش عاوزه
يبقى في اي علاقات من الصين لان الواردات
الصينيه تضرها هي بتدافع عن توتير العلاقه
مع الصين كل شركات الاسلحه
بتبالغ في الخطر الصيني لان هذا يعني
مزيدا من الاقبال على بضائعها حتى شركات
البنيه التحتيه ودي قصه عجيبه غريبه جدا
بتقف وراء مشروع
للرئيس الامريكي باستثمارات تصل الى مليار
اسف تريليون دولار امريكي التريليون دولار
دي لتحديث البنيه التحتيه الامريكيه هذه
الشركات سوف تستفيد منها وتجني ارباحا
هائله لكنها لتمرير هذه الفاتوره بتقول ان
السبب الرئيسي الذي يجب ان يدفعنا الى هذا
الاتجاه استثمار تريليون دولار في مشاريع
البنيه التحتيه هو رغبتنا في التفوق على
الصين التي سبقتنا في مشاريع البنيه
التحتيه ولا سبيلنا لمنافستهم الا بتحديث
بنيتنا التحتيه قصص طويله على كل الاحوال
هذا البالون
في هذه الاجواء ولهذه الاسباب جاء في اسوا
وقت للعلاقات الامريكيه الصينيه اللي هي
متوتره جدا في السنوات الاخيره بدات توتر
طبعا في اثناء رئاسه الرئيس ترامب ووصف ثم
فيروس كورونا اللي وصفه بانه فيروس صيني
ثم عشرات الاسباب الاخرى والحرب التجاريه
والعقوبات الامريكيه على الصين ويعني
الاجراءات المضاده من الصين لكن كان
البلدين بيسعيا في الشهور الماضيه لتهدئه
الاجواء وكل له حساباته الحسابات
الامريكي الصينيه انه انا غير قادره وغير
راغبه في توتير العلاقات بشكل مفتوح لعده
سنوات مع الامريكان خصوصا الان وانا ده هي
الصين يعني خارجه من
اضطرابات اقتصاديه كبيره بعد عمليه اغلاق
الاقتصادها لفتره طويله ثم عقوبات امريكيه
متعدده بتزيد يوم بعد يوم ضد شركاته
الكبرى
ومحاوله حرمانيه من التكنولوجيا الغربيه
المتطوره فكان الامل ان هم يهدئوا التوتر
مع الجانب الامريكي امريكا رحبت او في
قطاع في الولايات المتحده يرحب بالتهدئه
الان لان هم راغبين في ان هم يضربوا اسفين
ما بين الصين وما بين روسيا كما فعلت
امريكا سنه 72 لما تقربت من الصين بزياره
الرئيس نيكسون اللي هندسها وزير الخارجيه
وقتها على اساس انه يؤدوا الى يعني قطيعه
وتوتر هو كان في قطيعه وتوتر ما بين الصين
والاتحاد السوفيتي وقتها لكن ارادوا
استثماره وقد استثمروه فدلوقتي في قطاع في
امريكا بيقول انه الصين وروسيا اقرب
لبعضهما البعض منذ اي وقت مضى على الاقل
في الستين سنه الماضيه
وان هذا التقارب يضر الولايات المتحده في
رغبتها الان ترقيع روسيا واضعافها
للانتصار عليها على الاراضي الاوكرانيه
وبالتالي واحده من الوسائل انهم يقللوا
اندفاع الصين لدعم الروس على مستويات
متعدده في هذه المواجهه بين روسيا وبين
الغرب
فكان الطرفين راغبين في تقارب كل له
اسبابه وبدات تقارب ده يبان في بالي في
قمه بالي قمه العشرين لما الرئيس بايدن
قال للرئيس الصيني لا ارى ان حربا بارده
جديده ضروريه ابدا ما فيش داعي نعمل حرب
بارده مع بعض
وبدات عمليه ذوبان جليد بترحيب من الطرفين
التقى مسؤولين امريكان وصينيين في زيورخ
في سويسرا في يناير الماضي واكدوا على
رغبتهم في التعاون على مستويات متعدده تم
تحديد زياره
لوزير الخارجيه
كان موعدها خمسه وسته فبراير الماضي
لمناقشه قضايا عالقه
ظهر هذا البالون اللعين في
اخر يناير دم ضربه في اربعه فبراير قبل
يوم واحد من مغادره بلينكن المرتقبه للصين
فتم الغاء
وتوترت الاجواء اسوا من كل ذلك ان العام
الجاري 2023 بيحمل الكثير من فرص المواجهه
والتصعيد لا التهدئه بين البلدين اولا لان
العامل الجارح هو عام انتخابي في داخل
الامريكي والصين تحولت الى قضيه انتخابيه
بامتياز في امريكا لانها ارتبطت في اذهان
الكثير من الامريكان بانها اصل كل الشرور
وانها سبب رئيسي في المتابع متاعب
الاقتصاديه لهم وانها تسرق ملايين الوظائف
من الطبقه المتوسطه والفقيره هناك هكذا
صورها سياسيين امريكان لسنوات مضت في
اعوام الانتخابات بيتباهى الكثير من
الراغبين في الدخول الى الكونجرس او
الترشح للبيت الابيض بمواقفهم المتشدده من
الصين وعلى سبيل المثال كذب مكارثي رئيس
مجلس النواب الجمهوري الجديد يرغب في ان
يفعل ما فعلته نانسي بلوس رئيسه مجلس
النواب السابقه الديمقراطيه واعلن انه سوف
يزور تايوان قريبا ما يعني ان هناك انفجار
محتمل في العلاقه بين الولايات المتحده
والصين في الشهور المقبله ان فعلت طبعا ثم
ان الشهور المقبله بتحمل
فرص تصعيد الصراع ما بين الغرب وروسيا على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه
امريكا بتتهم الصين بانها تدعم روسيا بشكل
غير مباشر مع طول امد الصراع سوف تزداد
فرص التوتر بين الولايات المتحده والصين
على الجانب الاخر على الجانب الصيني
الرئيسي تشيبي يتعرض الى ضغوط من معسكرين
داخل الصين معسكر بيضغط عليه لمزيد من
الانفتاح على الغرب واصلاح ذات البين
وبيعتبروا انه فشل في اداره هذا الملف
الحيوي جدا للامن القومي الصيني
وفشل بمعنى انه ان العلاقات بين امريكا
والصين توترت في عهده اكثر مما توترت تحت
اي زعيم صيني اخر فيما ان هناك معسكر
المتشددين اللي بيسموهم ولف واريرز او
المحاربين الذئاب اللي يعتقدون ان
المصالحه في غير محلها وان المواجهه مع
الغرب والولايات المتحده هي الانسب صفعه
بصفعه
كان الطيار الذي يعني يتسيد المشهد في
الشهور الاخيره هو طيار التصالحيين
وبالتالي بدا ذوبان الجليد بين البلدين
وكانت هناك رغبه في تهدئه التوتر جاء
المنطاد اللعين
فعلى على على كافه
الذئاب في الصين وفي المقابل طبعا من
يتسيد المشهد في امريكا هم الصقور
الراغبين في المواجهه مع الصين وبالتالي
اصبحنا امام الذئاب الصينيين في مواجهه
الصقور الامريكان ما يعني ان الشهور
المقبله تحمل الكثير من فرص التوتر
والمواجهه ويبدو ايضا ان الرئيس الروسي قد
دعا الله وان الله قد استجاب اشكركم والى
لقاءات الاخرى باذن الله